I know I'm in the minority here but I  don't really like the Christopher Nolan  Batman movies I don't I really just feel  like they're  overrated  okay  well that's um that's just an opinion  you see that's why I prefaced it by  saying I know I'm in the minority  or you know what no no  not really it's not awkward at least not  until you said awkward now it's awkward  because of what you said  anyway anyway what anyway what really  because when you say anyway then you  have to follow it up with an actual  contribution to the conversation we're  having  yeah no look at me look at me look at me  look at me look at me there's no yikes  and the reason why there's no yikes is  there's nothing scary about this  situation okay it's a very low stake  situation all right